Because all of our entities are simulated using physics bodies, we lack the
ability to simply move our player to our desired position. This type of
teleportation can cause issues with your physics environment, mainly,
teleported objects ignore physics calculations until after their teleportation
has been resolved. For instance, if we move the player to a teleported position
which is intersected at the wall we could potentially get stuck there. And then
confuse the PhysicsEngine on what to do next, since the player is, of course,
stuck. As such, rather than teleporting the player we need to update it's
velocity such that the PhysicsEngine moves that unit to where we want it to go,
next update loop. Now all of our players actually have an mpPhysBody variable.
This physics body is given to us on the instantiation of the player, by
allocating it from the PhysicsEngine. Since we can't set the physics body
position directly, due to teleportation issues, what we do instead is a little
bit of a workaround. We take advantage of the fact that the PhysicsEngine is
going to update all of the physics bodies that it owns every frame. The physics
bodies themselves allow you to define a velocity vector on them. When the
PhysicsEngine updates, it adjusts the position of the physics body by the
vector, moving it correctly. We, in GRITS can take advantage of this. By
supplying a velocity vector that will move our physics body to the position we
want it to be in. Avoiding the teleportation issues.